(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
- They're still standing.
They're so excited.
I love the hair too.
- Ah.
- Like the gold in it.
- Everyone backstage was like,
"Kelly's gonna love your hair tinsel."
- I love it!
- I have a girl for you,
I have a girl for you.
- Oh my God, I'm gonna steal that idea.
Okay, so wait, I heard that
you have a new addition
from Christmas, right?
- Yes.
- To your home?
- Yes, I do.
I didn't have a say in this new edition.
- That's no fun.
- I was not consulted.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But you know what, we
have a new Corgi puppy,
you guys, in the house.
(audience cheering)
Because you know, we needed
it like a hole in our head.
- [Kelly] It's just like a baby.
- Yeah, we could have a human being.
- My puppy just turned one
and it's a having another
baby in the house.
Oh my gosh.
- You guys, those short
little legs are so cute.
So cute, I'm just like.
- I would snuggle so hard.
- Whose dog is that?
Whose dog is that?
And my husband and my son
were like, "It's ours."
I was like, "Oh."
- Oh my gosh.
- I know, and then my husband
tested positive for the flu
the next day.
- Oh, so you get to take care.
- And it was right before
Christmas Eve and Christmas,
so I did most of that by myself
with three kids and a new puppy and a dog,
and I was like, "This is
your last day on earth.
I hope you're enjoying yourself up there."
- No, you have more animals.
I have a lot of animals as well.
And you have chickens.
- Chickens.
- You have a lot of animals.
- Oh yeah, and with the flooding
that's happening right now.
- Yeah.
- Like I came home from work,
my husband and I are sweeping water
out of the chicken coop
and it was not fun.
- But your your daughter, Banks,
she also got a cool present, right,
for her birthday this year?
- She Did.
- Yeah.
- She did, I mean, she got
a lot of cool presents,
but I think the most exciting one for her,
as she's a massive Harry Styles fan.
- So is my son.
- Okay, so, I mean, so am I.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- So when we bought the tickets,
I was like, "This is for me."
- Me too.
- Kind of like the hair tinsel.
- I got a full on sweet girl.
I was like, "Yeah."
- It was so good,
and I have to tell you, Matt,
my husband watches the show.
I'm like, "Are you having a good time?
Are you enjoying this?"
And he's having the time of his life,
but he's just absorbing
and staring and there,
and I'm over here like,
"Yeah, we're partying.
I'm singing along."
- Yeah.
I'm you, I'm singing.
- I can't hear because
you're singing so loud
and embarrassing all of us.
And Banks did the same thing,
and when we were driving,
I thought she was gonna rip
her car seat out of the,
she was like every word,
just jamming so hard,
winding her window down, hair flying,
and then we got there and she was like-
- [Kelly] That's my son.
That's Remy.
- What's going on?
- [Kelly] He sat it
and it was almost like,
"How do I memorize all these
moves so I can be him?"
- [Hillary] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] It was like he was
just watching so intently.
- Taking notes.
- So cute.
- [Hillary] Taking note.
- [Kelly] So your youngest is May
and you just tried to
cut her bangs, right?
- I did.
- [Kelly] So, I guess I should say tried.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you succeeded.
- Don't insult me.
- Exactly.
- Look at those bings.
- I was like, my son,
literally last night asked
if I would cut his hair and
I was like, "Hard pass."
- (laughs) Bring him over to my house.
- You don't want me to cut your hair.
(both laugh)
So you're comfortable with that?
I feel like I'd make
my kid look ridiculous,
and yours look so cute.
- So.
- You even did a little shorter hair.
- I did.
- It's cute.
- So someone taught me that you make tri,
you basically split them in half
and then just do like a triangle,
like a that over the face.
And I did it, I just put
on freaking Cocomelon,
which is the savior to everything.
- Yeah.
- Or makes them quiet.
- And I cut 'em,
and then my husband cut me
off a couple weeks later,
'cause he was like, "One
cut, one trim per week.
I'm seeing you do this every day."
But it's weird because I'll be like,
"Oh, I left a little."
- Addictive.
- Yeah, and then I'll
just give her a popsicle
and then just get after it.
And he's like,
"She's gonna be like a
rockabilly chick in no time."
(Kelly laughing)
- Like can you calm down?
- Which is cute.
- Yeah, and now I found
this thing on Instagram,
of course they're all listening to us,
I got ad targeted.
Have you seen this little
shield that sticks to their face
and it's clear so you don't run the risk
of giving 'em a little snip by accident.
- I will never need that.
(all laughing)
I will never cut my children's hair.
- [Hillary] Okay.
- 'Cause see somebody could tell me,
"Oh, it's about triangles."
And then, yeah, no.
- You're like, she said circles.
She said circles.
- No, no. I'll just.
- And then it's a bowl cut.
- I will attempt triangle
and feel like I'm doing
exactly what you're doing
and fail miserably,
and then my kid will be
get made fun of at school.
- Yeah, my ex-husband
actually did that with my son.
He was like, "I tried to cut his hair."
He gave him a buzz cut and he-
- Nope.
- It was so short and he
was so upset about it.
- I'm him.
Yeah, I can't do it.
I think that's amazing that you can.
- Thanks.
- Also it's just annoying
that you fit all that
stuff in your schedule.
- You know what, add it to my resume.
My special talents list on my
resume just got bigger, guys.
(all laughing)
(audience cheers)
- That was a little bit of her show
"How I Met Your Father",
and you can see episodes Tuesdays on Hulu.
So what is Sophie up to this season?
- Oh my gosh.
The show is really fun this season, and-
- [Kelly] Oh, it's so fun.
- We're really like,
I feel like we're in our
stride, which is great.
And we get 20 episodes instead of 10.
Last year we had 10, we got 20 this year.
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
- I know.
So, it's a lot more storylines
and getting to dive deeper
into characters and stuff.
And Sophie is in this point in her life,
she's 30, and she just feels
people are moving past her
and she's a little bit at a standstill.
And she's not totally,
but she feels like that.
And so in the first few episodes
she starts to lie and they
start to be like casual
and then it's like this
snowball effect of lies
and she's just looking like a monster.
It's been really fun to play.
I'm not a great liar in real life.
- I was gonna say, are you a good liar?
I'm, yeah.
- I'm an actress, so I can tell a lie.
- So, then yes.
- But to my core, I'm also deeply a Libra,
and so I'm a truth seeker.
- Yeah.
- And also I'm kind of comfort,
if I feel someone's lying
to me, I cannot handle it.
I'm like-
- Yeah.
- We're getting down to the bottom.
I think I would've made a good lawyer.
- I think I just thank that person,
'cause I go, "Oh thank you.
I will pick that weed,
you are no longer allowed in the garden."
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, 'cause you can tell-
- [Hillary] So, you're just done.
- Yeah, I'm just kinda like-
- Well, you just know where to place them.
You're not it.
- I know where to place them,
Yeah, I don't-
- I think that it's situational.
- Yeah.
- For sure, but if it's
something that I really need
to get down to the bottom of, I'm like.
- I can lie though.
- You can?
- Yeah, and I'm not an actor, (laughs)
but I can lie,
because you know what?
I wanna know, I guess Chuck
E Cheese are closed today.
- [Hillary] Oh yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, Disneyland,
they're not open on Wednesday's.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
I lie a lot.
- You're like, "The TV
has to go to sleep now."
- Yeah, yeah.
I will just say whatever.
I have to do something tonight,
that's why you have to go.
- We have to survive.
- Yeah, 'cause you know what,
you do the whole thing
that therapists tell you,
and then just sometimes you're tired.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
- Well most of the time.
- Yeah.
And you're like, I don't
know, it's closed today,
that's so weird.
I'm mad too.
- Yeah.
- We would've had so much fun.
- I guess we're staying home.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- But I don't think I
got to this last time,
to ask you this last time we were here,
but how did you and your husband meet?
'Cause I know, Matt is
an incredible writer.
He literally wrote one
of my favorite songs
I've ever recorded.
Like, he's so talented.
So how did y'all meet?
Was it while you were
working in the studio?
- Yeah, well yes.
So we got set up, we were both at RCA.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And we got set up by
our A&R person there.
Not set up like that,
but just set up to work.
- Yeah.
- And I was cutting a couple of the songs
that he had written.
- So good.
- And met at Aroma Cafe
on Tujunga in the Valley,
and then we ended up being
there for like two hours talking
and I was like, "I gotta go.
What am I doing?"
Why are we talking about
all these nineties music
that we like and really connecting and-
- 'Cause you're cool and
nineties music is awesome.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So that's how we met.
And then we recorded a
little bit in the studio
and everything was pretty professional.
And then he asked me out on a date,
it was around Valentine's Day,
and then we casually started
dating a month after that,
and we broke up,
and then we got back together,
and then we broke up and
then we got back together.
- Oh, you did?
- And we were like, "We
should have a baby."
And then we had a baby
and I was like, if any
of my kids ever do that,
you're all gonna die.
(Kelly laughs)
But it worked out really great for us.
- Oh my God, I love this story.
This is a movie.
- Yeah, and 2 months later I was pregnant.
- Oh my gosh.
- I know, I know, naughty.
- But, he's so funny.
- He's so funny.
I mean, here's the thing.
I feel like, if someone
can make you laugh.
- [Hillary] I know.
- Like, you know what I'm saying?
Love changes.
- Really.
- It doesn't necessarily fade,
it just changes I feel like.
But, if someone can make you laugh,
that's what we're all looking for,
'cause that's always gonna
be awesome to be around.
He is funny.
I have to show you this.
He has such a good sense of humor.
Here is his Grammy campaign,
which you literally have to read,
it's not just the picture.
He is so clever with
the writing on the side.
It's just, I think he's so funny.
- "Life's a piece of
cake when you're rich."
- Yes.
- One Republic featuring Ryan Tedder.
- I just need loves needs new feature.
(both laughing)
He's so funny.
- Well the thing is,
all these people were
posting their own things,
and he is like, "What is this?"
- [Kelly] I know, and he's ripping on it.
- What's going on?
- It's funny.
I know, I think that's so funny.
So, and he also did this,
he replaced their faces in the house
to see if you would notice, I guess.
- Yeah.
- With the Jonas Brothers.
Did you notice?
- On, on our framed photos.
Okay, well here's what I did notice.
We get "People" magazine in the mail,
and so I saw the magazine
and it was shredded sitting on the counter
and it was the Jonas Brothers one.
I'm like, I don't even
know what to think about,
my kids probably did something
weird with this magazine.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah
- [Hillary] Right.
And so, then, you guys, that's
my birthing photo, okay.
- [Kelly] That's so brave.
- [Hillary] And so then he had cut all the
Jonas Brothers heads out
and put them on all of our
framed photos in the house.
He's so weird.
- [Kelly] If weird means awesome.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
It's just so fun to like.
- And he waited.
He waited until I noticed,
and it took a couple of days for me to-
- Which says something.
- Oh.
- Maybe not so observant
in your household.
- Yeah.
Well there's just a million
things happening all the time.
- You have three kids
have a lot of animals,
I get it.
No, no, no, I get it.
- But he's a really great prankster
and honestly some of
the posts on Instagram,
if you don't follow him on
Instagram, it's quite a laugh.
Sometimes his stuff is so
weird, it goes over my head.
I'm like, I didn't get that one.
And then the other ones I'm like,
"I'm dead, you're so funny."
- Yeah.
- What's going on?
- He is.
The reason why I ask is it just seems
like you have such a cute relationship,
like friendship as well.
- Totally, we do.
- That's cool.
- We do.
And you know, he's a real chatty guy, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At the end of the day,
when I come home from work and I'm tapped,
he downloads all the
information to me from the day
and he gives me all current events
and his hot takes on everything.
- Yeah.
- He's just great.
But I left a note, I went
to New York last week
and I left a note for my kids,
'cause I left at like 4:00 AM,
and I'm like, "Love you
family, I'll miss you guys."
And he just posts on
Instagram a picture of it,
and he's like "I think my wife left me."
(all laughing)
- But meanwhile, when
you were on the plane,
were you just living your best life?
- The best, the best.
But then I got-
- You're not taking care of anything.
- I got a scallop allergy.
- What?
- Yes, I had a scallop allergy.
We didn't talk about this on the-
- I'm allergic to shrimp
and scallops as well, yeah.
- Apparently I am now too.
And so my two nights away from my kids,
where I was like, "I'm gonna sleep."
I'm gonna do all the walking I want."
- [Kelly] Oh no!
- My lip blew up huge.
My eye blew up huge, I looked insane.
I was hosting my friend's baby shower.
- Oh no.
- And I also, my husband suspects
I have a scallop allergy.
- I would say there's something happening.
- Well, there's always
been something happening,
but I wake up and my lips are swollen.
I'm like, kind of cute.
(audience laughing)
Don't mind this.
- But your eye, that's not.
- Well this time it was like ba, boom,
and then my eye and I was like,
"Cool, cool, I got an allergy."
I should take it seriously.
- I think your family should
just be recorded all the time.